[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a chinese comedy drama film
called how to train our dragon spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
jackson is a six-year-old kid who is in
love with his classmate one day he
presents her with a marriage certificate
asking her to sign it when the girl
refuses he offers her two movie tickets
in return for her being his wife she
signs the papers but uses the tickets to
go on a date with another boy nothing
like getting cocked when you're six
jackson has five elder sisters who are
overprotective of him seeing him
heartbroken they vow to protect him from
the female gender for the rest of their
lives the scene shifts 15 years into the
future jackson has grown up to become a
handsome man but with no privacy from
his sisters we are also introduced to
all five of his sisters the youngest
lily is in the same class as him then
there is violet who is a member of the
archery club she often uses her skills
to make jackson do what she wants the
third sister is a computer hacker named
heaven she breaks into the school's
security system to keep an eye on her
brother the second eldest sister is
melody she is the teacher of the high
school jackson goes to lastly the eldest
one is sarah she is the short-tempered
one who everyone is scared of their
parents divorced a long time ago leaving
the girls to take care of each other and
their brother one day at school jackson
is tired of being followed around by his
sisters his friend makes him a
camouflage suit to help him hide from
them jackson ends up inside a girl's
shower room locker in an attempt to
camouflage but a new girl named meng
finds him there and takes him to the
academic affairs office jackson doesn't
mind getting in trouble as long as his
sisters do not know anything about it
after school he nervously walks home
hoping that the second oldest sister
melody wasn't informed by the
administration when no one mentions the
events of the day he sighs with relief
but during dinner melody casually
mentions him being found in the girl's
locker room everyone looks at the eldest
sister sarah who turns red in anger in
the following scene they are dragging
jackson across the floor he is hung
upside down and asked what he was doing
in the girl's locker room the girls have
forbidden him to make eye contact with
any girl in an attempt to keep him from
getting his heart broken although the
method is a little extreme they think it
is best for jackson however he doesn't
share their views for the first time in
his life he retaliates and claims that
he needs to date a girl someday sarah
composes herself before challenging him
to find a girlfriend who would match all
of his sister's energies the task is
difficult but jackson is willing to take
it on the next morning he makes a board
advertising the vacancy for a girlfriend
his friend suggests he talked to the new
girl mang because she seems to be the
type who wants to help everyone she's
also the one that caught him in the
locker room so she's sure to give him a
shot a montage shows us meng helping
people with the things they don't really
need help with jackson agrees to make
her his girlfriend but has no experience
in talking to girls hence his friend
acts as a wingman and goes to meng to
boast about jackson he calls jackson a
victim of his sister's torture and lists
out all the things that the girls have
done to him after hearing the stories
mang feels sympathetic she walks toward
jackson to make friends with him but
changes her mind on looking at him
closely suddenly someone spreads the
news about a wild bear attacking the
students jackson plays the hero and
pretends to save everyone but it turns
out the bear is a stuffed toy even the
toy pushes him down the stairs which
lands him in a hospital in the following
scene jackson wakes up and finds himself
on a hospital bed with mang by his side
although the plan didn't work as he
wanted it to he gets to spend more time
with mang she tells him that she wants
to be his friend out of pity then two of
jackson's sisters arrive and start
bullying him for not taking care of
himself this angers men and she orders
them to stop as the girls look at her in
shock she introduces herself as
jackson's girlfriend a sick jackson
jerks up in surprise at the comment at
home his sisters subtly ask him if he
really has a girlfriend he just smirks
at the question and doesn't give them a
definite reply that is until the eldest
sister sarah asks him and he has to tell
her about meng the sisters again tie him
upside down not believing he was able to
get a girlfriend in just a day jackson
insists that it was love at first sight
but the girls do not buy it still they
decide to judge meng's eligibility to
see if she is good enough for their
brother the following day violet melody
and lily come to the school like it is
their battleground when jackson and mang
are together violet tries to shoot her
with an arrow but jackson stops it just
in time meng notices this and calls the
girls out for being cruel they stand
face to face challenging each other when
violet's method doesn't work lily takes
the matter into her hands she blackmails
all the handsome guys in the school to
approach mang and ask her out on a date
she hopes to waver ming's love for
jackson but the plan fails miserably
jackson helps men get away from the guys
as they run down the corridor violet
spots them from the other side of the
school and is about to shoot again but
this time she accidentally hits an
explosive that someone threw in the air
just before it causes an explosion
mid-air that thankfully doesn't harm
anyone while everyone is confused about
what caused the explosion we see a man
in a chemistry lab preparing more
explosives his motive is unclear but he
seems to have saved mang from violet
after the disaster jackson and meng come
to the terrace and enjoy popsicles
together jackson finds out that mang is
pretending to be his girlfriend because
she thinks his sisters are trying to
steal his organs he doesn't correct her
deciding to keep her in the dark for as
long as he can at home lily and violet
embarrassingly admit that they have
failed heaven who is good with computers
takes the responsibility to end meng's
reputation she collects random cctv
footage of meng from school and makes up
a lie about her being a horrible person
right before she uploads it on the
internet the power goes out we see that
the guy from the chemistry lab is
outside their house he is the one who
cut the power to save mang but his true
intentions are still unknown inside the
house the three sisters who failed kneel
in front of the second oldest melody it
is now her responsibility to get rid of
mang the following day she challenges
meng to a sports meet they go against
each other in a staring competition and
a goldfish collecting challenge both of
which melody wins and shows meng her
place nothing proves you're a loser like
goldfish collecting they are about to
compete for a final round when the
eldest sister sarah arrives she
introduces herself before challenging
meng for a match of the hammer throw
they have to throw a heavy metal ball as
far away as possible using her
exceptional skills sarah levitates the
ball mid-air when it is her turn to
throw she picks up another ball from the
stand we notice that a key comes out of
the ball revealing that it was spiked
with an explosive that is about to go
off any second mang notices this and
snatches the ball away from sarah before
throwing it away when it explodes sarah
realizes that her life was saved she
starts to like meng which makes the
other sisters respect her as well
jackson runs around the field thanking
god for bringing meng into his life the
scene is then followed by a montage of
jackson and meng spending time together
they go on several dates finally
converting from a fake couple to a real
one as they get to know more about each
other they like each other even more on
one of their romantic dates they go to
an empty beach and spend the night
together in the morning they playfully
fight and hug each other throughout all
this the chemist guy is spying on them
the hug makes his blood boil in anger
but he doesn't do anything for the
moment the next day at school the
youngest sister lily and jackson are
together lily opens a lunch box that has
been fitted with an explosive suddenly a
loud explosion shakes the entire school
jackson is fine but lily has to be given
cpr to be brought back to consciousness
thankfully it was only a chemical
explosion and everyone is safe meng
notices jackson and his sisters huddled
together in fear and realizes how much
they love each other she walks away from
the scene and is followed by jackson
they bump into each other but meng
completely ignores him and the fact he
could have died earlier jackson is
confused and heartbroken but he doesn't
ask her what is wrong in reality meng
has figured out that the bad things
happening to jackson and his sisters
only started when she started dating him
she thinks she brings a bad omen into
their lives and decides to stay away
jackson tries to talk to her repeatedly
but she continues ignoring him one night
it rains heavily in the town jackson is
at home when he sees the news about the
flooded streets he remembers that meng
was in the school waiting for the rain
to stop when he last saw her he
immediately rushes to the school to find
her struggling to stand up because of
the rain wow she's useless jackson hugs
her asking her to return to her normal
self but mang reluctantly pushes him
aside it turns out that she is about to
transfer schools again and wants him to
stay away from her until then a hurt
jackson stays under the rain all night
in the morning he hears someone
approaching him from behind he mistakes
the person for mang and hugs them but it
is the man who has been creating the
explosives until now he tases jackson
and abducts him that evening there is a
party at the school everyone is enjoying
the live music and the show while mang
sulks in a corner the sisters are tense
because of jackson's absence they try
their best to catch him and find that
his phone is somewhere nearby after a
firework display a strange masked man
takes over the stage he is the kidnapper
who had tied jackson to a rocket that he
claims is about to fly away on being
asked the reason for the haterade he
reveals that he is invisible to everyone
and has no friends he fell in love with
mang at first sight and was always
around her he saved her from jackson's
sisters but still mang loved no one
other than jackson hence he is here to
take revenge on jackson who stole the
only happiness in his life the sisters
mang and many of jackson's friends try
their best to hold the rocket down they
are successful but it only stops for a
few seconds before flying away jackson
confesses how much he loves mang at last
he launches towards the sky and dies in
the following explosion in the following
scene we see mang in front of a grave
she offers it flowers and asks for
blessings suddenly jackson jumps into
frame revealing he was only injured in
the last accident but is perfectly well
other than a broken hand the grave is
actually of meng's mother who died a
long time ago in the last scene we see
the sisters arrive and trouble jackson
as usual subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching